[Music]
today we're reviewing amd's RX 7900 XTX
the 1 000 video card rdna3 that's
launching while we're on the other side
of the world but we're still going to
review it and test it in time for this
embargo lift because this thing's pretty
interesting and this has impressive
performance and rasterization and at a
thousand dollars to MSRP Nvidia risks
becoming seriously displaced by AMD if
it continues to ignore the more
affordable price class of gpus as it's
done with the 4080 which is 1200 bucks
the 4090 at least it has the technical
best category but at 1600 it's not cheap
either now a thousand dollars for amds
still isn't cheap clearly there's my 100
7900 XT we're also reviewing today but
there's still a dearth of options in the
Sub 900 a mid-range category right now
and that is where we think the battle
will move next in early next year the
overcast cloudy sky and the rain is sort
of symbolic of the despair that Gamers
have felt trying to find affordable gpus
for about a generation now actually it's
just raining and we didn't have anywhere
else to film and I already shouted into
a mattress in the Airbnb for the
voiceover starting with Rainbow Six
Siege test but it's still kind of
symbolic let's get started with the 7900
XTX review and see how it does versus
nvidia's 4080 especially before that
this video is brought to you by Arctic
and the liquid freezer 2 liquid coolers
now including an argb model in the
lineup the liquid freezer Series has
been a top performer in our Benchmark
for years now and Arctic has continually
fine-tuned its products even post launch
with things like tits for ryzen argb
fans for new flare and new radiator
sizes the company also has its brand new
MX6 thermal paste on the market now
learn more at the links in the
description below so quick recap for you
first of all the 700 XTX and the 700 XT
are the ones that are launching tomorrow
the reviews go up a day in advance
thousand dollars and 900 respectively
for those we already covered the specs
and the architecture for rdna 3 as a
separate video those are on the channel
if you want to check them out we'll link
them in the description below rather
than rehashing them here if you need to
get up to speed on it now the 40 80 12
gigabyte is expected to get a Rebrand
and a price drop as well in January
that'll likely be around CES timing but
for now for today it's not out and we
don't know what it's going to cost so
it's relevant to the discussion because
only the 4080 and 40 90 are out right
now in the 4D series our benchmarks
Today Show that the XTX is a seriously
competitive and rasterization and it's
in the maybe close enough territory for
some Ray tracing but it gets blown out
of the water and others depending on
what the testing is like cyberpunk for
example so Ray tracing is hit and miss
and that's going to be the key
Battleground where AMD needs to gain a
foothold in the future and as for
mechanical design it's something that
we're looking at in the tear down
specifically but we'll also have
pressure tests and flatness testing on
this one so let's get straight into the
benchmarks we'll start with power
testing for the benchmarks we ran
transients and we ran nominal power
consumption alike transients allow us to
observe 100 to 200 microsecond bursts up
to 300 microseconds where the power
consumption really spikes hard and it's
enough to potentially knock power
supplies offline if the GPU spikes too
high above its nominal draw so we'll be
looking at that but first we need to
look at the average power consumption to
get an idea for what it pulls when
playing games or working and averaging
over the transients we'll start with the
easier one average power consumption in
a power virus workload sets us off the
RX 7900 XTX ran at 351 Watts during load
which is right around its 355 watt TDP
that hasn't consuming more power than
the RTX 4080 stock card by about 40
Watts or an 11 increase in power draw
the 49d pulls 41 more power than the 700
XTX and you'll see in the benchmarks
that these numbers often actually align
with the performance differences as well
generationally the 6900 XT pulled almost
the same 350 Watts since a standalone so
AMD has stayed approximately within its
power envelope over the years now for
transient testing in this Benchmark we
use an oscilloscope and we clamp the
cables to monitor actively for Peak
power spikes this allows us to see if
there are any poor power design
characteristics in the video card it's
at the PCB level and the architecture
level alike and it helps us see if your
power supply might shut down or if you
might need to accommodate a higher power
Peak draw when building your system
inspecting it out in transit testing we
entered some serious coil one or as
Stone from our team wrote holy coil wine
Batman when running the high FPS
scenarios
we noticed that none of the transients
reached one millisecond in duration with
most at 500 microseconds or less this is
different from the 40 90 where the
transients weren't as spiky in the
vertical Direction but we noticed that
horizontally they were longer in
duration this time the worst Peak for
the XTX was in Rainbow Six Siege at
1440p where we measured a transient
Spike at 92.6 percent higher than
nominal power we also observed the 100
microsecond Spike to 725 watts and the
loading screen for do maternal although
we had difficulty replicating this
particular behavior and we don't have a
scope shot of it happening that
unpredictable nature is worse than
predictable reproduction though because
it means that it could strike at any
time and depending on the power supply
quality potentially knock it offline we
saw power consumption in the range of
680 to 690 Watts for transient spikes
and high FPS gaming scenarios
additionally we noticed that the
reference 700 xdx has some voltage
regulation issues it dropped as low as
11 volts under Peak current loads in
some scenarios down from a clean 12.0
and that most likely comes down to the
reference board AMD probably won't be
out doing its partners for power design
delivery and thermals unlike nvidia's
internally competitive Fe this is an
area where AMD needs to do some power
delivery cleanup work now for pressure
testing in this one we use a special
chemically reactive paper we reassemble
the GPU with that paper in between the
GPU and the cold plate for the cooler we
get all the screws back in it so that we
can see if amd's pressure and mounting
solution for the cooler to the GPU core
has improved over the last couple
Generations where they've had some
trouble here here's the pressure map
overlaid on a photo of the XTX and we'll
zoom in closer the bottom mcds are
lacking in pressure which makes sense
given that the screws are primarily
located at the left the right flanks and
above there aren't many below the GPU
the leftmost edge of the gcd is also
lacking in pressure the pressure over
all is good there's coverage of the
majority of the dies but lacking in the
bottom area shows that some different
screw locations or a different design
for the base plate might resolve this
issue this is not a GPU specific problem
it's a board plus cooler problem so it's
something that the board Partners can
work on lack of pressure though doesn't
mean lack of contact it just means
reduced contact pressure at those points
and AMD has improved generationally in
massive ways with its reference designs
over the last two generations including
this one so it's still a move in the
right direction here's the flatness
testing results the reference 7900 XTX
has a median point-to-point depth and
microns of 13 with the maximum at 22 as
an outlier the median Point depth is
overall good on the reference card this
is a scenario where it's not the best
we've seen but it's also not bad in any
way and or is it particularly relevant
as difference overall for what we're
seeing here time to get into gaming AMD
talked a lot about 8K so let's start
with that since it's apparently so
important to AMD that it was worth
spending in a good amount of its
performance discussion on front's
presentation total Warhammer 3 at 8K is
first as you can see we've ensured the
scale is appropriate to fit the massive
performance we're definitely going to
see the 7900 XTX ran at 24 FPS average
at 8K allowing the RTX 490 Elite of 38
at 32 FPS average the RTX 4080s 28 FPS
average allowed at a lead of 18 so great
that's that's exciting and we're glad
that Nvidia and AMD have both decided
that this point is worth talking about
with Nvidia doing it for the 3091st at
AMD doing it now and making the same
mistakes cyberpunk with FSR and dlss at
so-called eight so-called K so-called
gaming had the 3090 TI at 13 and the
4080 at 7.4 FPS average it did worse
than the 3090 TI when we did validation
testing we realized that's because we
were Bound by GPU memory and the 309 DTI
has more than the 4080 so it helped it
here the RX 7900 XTX ran out and
impressive show stopping 11.6 FPS
average show stopping because you it's
one-fifth of a playable frame rate and I
think we can all agree that this was a
good use of time just like it was an
amd's presentation so let's move on to
something less useful like 4K and 1440p
gaming in Total War 3 at 4K the RX 7900
XTX ran at 91 FPS average with low space
similarly to other gpus at 70 and 65.
that allows the RTX 4090 a lead of 37
percent at 60 percent higher MSRP or in
other words it allows the 700 xdx to
achieve at 73 of the performance of the
4090 at 63 percent of the price compared
to the RTX 4080 the 7900 XTX is
functionally equal in average FPS and is
proportional in loads but the XTX has
the benefit of being cheaper the RTX
4080 still has one major advantage
though it's the most vocal on the nose
overbearing cash grab we've seen from
Nvidia since they launched sorry
unlaunched the 40 80 12 gigabyte for
other cards the 700xdx out does the
6800x team that 50 more expensive than
the current price or compared to the
original MSRP of a thousand dollars at
launch the same price the 5700 XT and
Vega 64 cards are also plotted for
owners of previous flagships but we'll
just highlight them and then move
forward we're moving on to Total War at
1440p last generation AMD gains
disproportionately High Ground at 1440p
and 1080p so we'll see if it can repeat
that behavior here the RTX 4090 ran at
236 FPS average year leading the 180 FPS
average of the 700 XTX by 31 percent
reduced from 37 percent at 4K so AMD is
still gaining ground at least in this
one when below 4K compared to Nvidia
that is the RX 7900 XTX has a technical
lead of about two percent over the RTX
4080 at a significant cost reduction
MSRP to MSRP compared to last gen Parts
the 700 XTX leads the 6950 XT by 45 or
the 6900 XD by 58 realistic upgrades
might include the RX 5700 XT to the 7900
XTX which jumps from 56 FPS average to
180 or Vega 64 at its original 45 FPS
average so with either of these you'd
see a massive increase to a 7000 series
GPU of stay in AMD at 1080p the 700 XTX
encroaches on the 4090 in part thanks to
approaching the CPU limitations there's
only a 22 lead for NVIDIA here that
widen with a higher end CPU so it's not
a pure comparison but the 7800 XTX
versus the 4080 is as the 49d shows us
the ceiling is still distant for either
of these two cards the 700 XTX is
functionally the same as the 4080 but
with a technical Victory as for the 6950
XT or the 6900 XT it's about 40 to 45
percent ahead generationally lows
haven't changed in scale either between
the 4080 and the 700 xdx the XTX still
makes more sense in pure rasterization
based on at least this game but we need
to look at some more shadow of the Tomb
Raider at 4K is next this game behaves
differently from Total Warhammer and
it's useful for seeing another side of
performance the 700 XTX ran at 143 FPS
average in this one and it didn't have
any issues with the lows like most other
cards recently tested that has the 4080
at 3.5 percent ahead of the 700 XTX for
20 more MSRP the 4090 is a more
substantial 41 percent ahead so at least
that one is still kind of defensible as
being the literal best there's some
value there whereas the 4080 loses the
mandatory value argument because it's
below the flagship it has to have value
and it just doesn't and it never really
did versus some previous flagships
here's how it lines up the 7900 XTX
leads the 6900 XT by 38 the 5700 XT by
170 percent Vega 64 by 249 and the RX
580 because why not by 450 percent it's
a high enough percentage that it becomes
truly stupid to even compare with
percentages and instead just becomes the
point of anything as an upgrade so you
shouldn't think about it too hard
because you're going to notice the
difference at 1440p the rx700 XTX ran at
232 FPS average allowing the 4088
technical but irrelevant lead the 4090
is bouncing off the CPU ceiling here so
it isn't a valid comparison versus last
gen we're looking at a 15 uplift over
the 6950 XT this resolution is limiting
us with this game so let's just move on
to another one in Final Fantasy at 4K
the 7900 XTX ran at 148 FPS average and
was again within functional equivalence
of the RTX 4080 for rasterization and
videos and rough shape for its only
other current gen offering the 4090 at
least keeps its 45 lead that we've seen
in other tests allowing Nvidia to retain
the technical best Crown until AMD can
contest it at some point with something
higher at but the real battle honestly
is going to be in the mid-range of next
year it's not at the high end and it
never really has been the high end is
nice for Halo marketing but that's not
where most people buy even still the
4090 remains an impressive card with a
nearly comical lead over nvidia's own
4080. the 700 XTX leads even the 3090 TI
by 21 sorry early 30 90 TI buyers but
the 3090 TI was around two thousand
dollars at launch is double the price of
the 700 XTX MSRP today compared to the
700 or so-ish dollar 6900 XT if you buy
it today that is the XTX leads by about
42 percent for an equal amount more
money but that's versus the modern
reduced price not the launch on SRP we
tested 1440p but this game is just too
easy to run and it was bound on guards
even from last generation so let's move
on the next one has a very limited data
set because we just updated the game for
F1 2022 we only recently pushed a few
gpus through to start building your
charts but we got the 700 XTX on there
the 4090 predictably leads it's at 205
if he has average at 4K with a 700 XCX
in second place at 164. lows are scaling
as expected here and the 4090 has about
a 25 lead in this one with the 700xcx
managing to outperform the 4080 once
again but this time by a more
significant margin than previously now
at nine percent that's outside of the
functional equivalence we saw earlier
and it's at 4K no less so that's pretty
good spacing the lead over the 6950xt is
about 23 percent with the lead over
previous Flags rips like the 5700 XT and
the Vega 64. back into that territory of
anything as an upgrade at 1440p in our
limited Suite here for F1 the 4090 leads
the 700 XTX by just 9 nine percent it's
becoming CPU bound that's useful though
because it tells us that the 4K results
were not CPU bound yet the 700 XTX
architecture scales disproportionately
well in this game compared to the
previous Tomb Raider and total Warhammer
benchmarks the lead of XTX over the 4080
it's about 9.5 percent here growing from
nine percent previously in Rainbow Six
Siege at 4K the 4090 ran at 355 FPS
average to the xt-axis to 70. supporting
a 31 lead in the 40 90. the XTX is
almost exactly tied with the 4080 for
average FPS here technically speaking
the 700xcx is running disproportionately
lower one percent 0.1 metrics than its
RTX 40 flanks with the 4080 supporting
better frame time consistency than the
XTX but again that's technically
speaking realistically speaking these
differences aren't that meaningful when
factoring in the inherently wider error
on low calculation and the fact that
these numbers are so high anyway there's
just no tangible change the next card
down is the 3090 TI About 30 FPS behind
the 4080 and the 700 XTX obviously
owners of a 6950 XT 6900 xt380 or a
similar card have no need to upgrade at
this point those are all still great
devices and you really shouldn't be
doing single generation upgrades unless
there's some serious need but jumping
from a 20 series or a 5700 XT would net
pretty large improvements at 1440p the
4090 leads the 700 XTX by 17 percent we
know our ceilings about 677 FPS average
here but even though we have some room
between the 624 and the 677 number some
of the higher performing scenarios in
this test still hit that limiter the
4080 and the XTX are Unbound though and
that's good for this comparison the XTX
outguns the 4080 by 30 FPS average which
is a six percent lead that's in line
with some previous tests the XCX is
compelling as a more value-oriented
rasterization focused solution compared
to the clearly too expensive 4080 it
helps to look at something of Vulcan too
so he ran strange Brigade as a function
test strange Brigade is extremely well
optimized it has Vulcan and dx12 and
it's an interesting Benchmark for
evaluating performance even if it's not
that common of a game or ever was
strange Brigade had the 49 he had 291
FPS average with the 4080 and about 202
FPS average that 4080 number is about
the same as the 700 XTX once again
establishing that equivalence is the
worst case scenario for the 700 XCX in
general rasterization performance thus
far that's a fine place to be when your
card is cheaper in Horizon zero Dawn at
4K for the last purely rasterization
test the rx700 XTX ran at 121 FPS
average sitting just behind the RTX 4080
the 4090 leads at 164 FPS average which
is a 36 advantage to the 700 XTX as for
the rest the next closest card is the 39
DTI at 107 FPS average and then it's the
6950 XT at 99. now we're moving on to
Ray tracing tests these are our last
gaming benchmarks for this suite and
they're really difficult to run now
because for Ray tracing you have not
just RT performance but you have the FSR
or rsr or dlss or X ESS Solutions where
these technologies will allow super
resolution or super sampling to achieve
a sort of fake to higher resolution and
we need to test with all of those
depending on which game it is in
cyberpunk 2077 for the first one at 4K
with Ray tracing we're using the
equivalent dlss and FSR Technologies
between AMD and Nvidia so neither is
rendering at the pure unsupported 4K and
both are supported by their super
resolution Tech but we've configured
their quality settings so that they are
scaling from equivalent starting points
that makes it like for like comparable
the rx7900 XTX loses a lot of ground
here falling down to the performance
level of an RTX 3090 or a TI at best the
RTX 4080 leads by 40 percent a
staggering gain compared to the
rasterization tests and the 490 leads by
93 percent it's not even close
generationally over the 6950 XT Andy has
at least gained 46 percent in RT
performance which is a lot but it's just
not enough to get anywhere close to
Nvidia if you care about RT performance
in this game when we went to double
check the performance numbers we noticed
that amd's own reviewer reference data
suggested that the 7500 XTX would be
significantly worse than cyberpunk with
rt on so they got that right this is
expected Behavior at least at 1440p the
RX 7900 XTX ran at 78 FPS average in the
same test which has it between the 3090
and the ti this establishes another
large lead for the 40 series at 41 for
the 4080 and 75 percent for the 490. now
that the cyberpunk bloodbath is over we
can move on to Tomb Raider which is an
easier RT test it only implements
raytrained Shadows which means that it's
still primarily rasterization driven
with some Ray tracing on top and that
should be beneficial for AMD but it's
also representative of a lot of the
earlier titles for RT at 4K the 700 xdx
is still behind the RTX 4080. the 4080
leads by 11 this time which is outside
the range we saw for purely
rasterization but not as large a lead as
heavier games like cyberpunk the 4090
runs at 120 FPS average so the xdx is 78
and the 390 runs at 60fps average again
to the same 78 for the XTX so at least
against the last gen the AMD card looks
good but it does lose ground with rt at
1440p the 700 XTX ran at 140 FPS average
and allowed another 11 lead to the 4080.
the results scale the same here as they
did at 4K despite amd's lower resolution
performance swings we saw in some non-rt
titles control is up next back to more
heavily ranged raised games our
community voted this as one of their top
played RT titles alongside cyberpunk in
this one the RX 7900 XTX ran at 45 FPS
average at 4K with the 4080 at 52 FPS
average a lead of 14 for the 4080 the 40
90s 76 FPS average establishes it 70
ahead which is one of the few times that
the price is increasing roughly in step
with the performance increase and it
doesn't fall into a negative scale for
this comparison at 1440p control
positioned the 40 80 13 ahead of the
7900 XTX the 4080 really needs to come
down in price to be more competitive
here because only having a lead
sometimes in raid tracing isn't good
enough given the overall performance of
the 700 XTX even remotely we wanted to
bring you the full depth we bring you
for any other GPU reviews so we also ran
thermal testing for this we used a mix
of gpuz and Hardware info engineering
Edition to collect internal sensor
information we typically also mount
thermocouples to the board for further
validation however since I'm in Taiwan
right now we'll rely on the software
it's normally pretty accurate though
here's a chart of results at equilibrium
the GPU temperature aligns with amd's
software and with GPU Z and Hardware
info and it plots at 64 degrees Celsius
for the edge temperature or the lowest
of the GPU measurement the GPU has
multiple hotspots now with its chiplet
design with the gcd at 80 degrees
Celsius and the mcds all around 64 to 67
degrees Celsius these numbers are
acceptable the mcds especially the 80
degree number though is pushing the warm
side and you'll have some clock loss in
a hotter case so make sure you either
buy a more powerful partner model cooler
or you get a really good case although
amd's new cooler is better than its past
coolers this is by no means one that
we'd classify as impressive it's at best
pretty standard Partners will still out
do AMD here which is fine that's sort of
their job and how it's supposed to work
memory is more of a problem the memory
hotspot at 84 degrees Celsius when at 21
degrees Celsius ambient means that we
have very limited scaling room and
warmer case configurations because the
fan curve follows GPU temperature it
won't compensate on memory thermals
independently this can and has caused
problems with cards in the past the
thermistor and the fan blade although a
very cool idea and one we're excited
about isn't working in an ideal way it's
detected at 33 degrees Celsius even
though the actual Inlet temperature if
monitored by an external probe is 21
degrees Celsius that's because the
thermistor is so close to the warm motor
in The Fan Hub and the heat on the fin
stack that it's picking up more GPU
temperature than anything else in terms
of ambient an approximate 10 degree
Delta of true ambient open air to
internal GPU ambient is enough to know
how at least to use this number in your
case this can still be useful as a
number for configuring your case bands
because it's ultimately all relative
just know that it's not an absolute
indicator of true case ambient in the
region of Inlet for the GPU but as
stated if it changes when you move the
fans around that's still useful you just
need to look at the Deltas not the
absolute amd's cooler is okay it's
better than the last two generations
it's just again not something that we'd
say is anything beyond acceptable for a
reference model this one follows the
older trend of buying partner models to
see which ones can really knock it out
of the park if they can stick close to
MSRP and if they can't well then at
least this one's not overheating as for
the noise that's more of a problem aside
from the coil line issues this card also
ramps the fan extremely hard and very
early in the workload fan hysteresis is
not properly configured in vbios because
you can see it spikes from 0 to 700 RPM
nearly instantaneously when the load
starts it then drops a little bit and
then within just 60 more seconds it hits
its Max fan speed at 1700 RPM this type
of Rapid ramp is very noticeable to the
end user and is too aggressive because
in scenarios where the load might not
sustain more than a minute it's not
enough to justify the sudden noise hike
and then drop and these should just
adjust the fan wrap curve to be finer we
also ran frequency testing in fire
strike Ultra with custom settings we
observe the frequency in the range of
2600 to 2720 megahertz it's spikier than
we see on the modern Nvidia hardware and
in this case that's because AMD is
running up against both power and
voltage reliability limits that's normal
it has to hit some kind of limit it's
just a question of which limiter it is
and it's better to hit something like
vrel or power than it is to hit thermal
so Behavior here is what we classify as
expected so the 7900 XTX after looking
at all that it kicks Nvidia in the ass
for rasterization really it's cheaper at
worst it's about equivalent which is a
really good spot to be if you're already
cheaper and Nvidia is kind of a wake-up
call for them because they haven't ever
sold out of 4080s they've been on the
shelves in at least a few places ever
since launch and they still are today so
Nvidia needs to drop the prices and it
really needs to get another card out at
the cheaper end as well to start
fighting AMD harder here's a quick recap
of some of the numbers we looked at
today though so we observed about 350
Watts power draw nominally on the XTX
which is fair it's not particularly high
it's not particularly impressive either
on the efficiency side but it's a big
generational Improvement in the power
envelope over our DNA too a
rasterization had the 700 xdx often
equal with the RTX 4080 they went back
and forth in single digit percentages
and the ray Trace testing was more of a
blowout victory for NVIDIA and cyberpunk
which has known issues for amd's cards
per AMD directly we validated FSR was
working and it still performed poorly
even with that for control however in
Tomb Raider we observed that the 4080s
lead was significantly reduced and more
comparable between them and he still
isn't winning an RT performance and it
does need to catch up soon but it's
closed the Gap considerably over the
years now despite the pretty competitive
rasterization performance one area where
AMD really needs to do some work is its
power management on the board the 100
microsecond spiked the 725 Watts was
egregious but not nearly as bad as the
3080 was or the 30 90 gigabyte Master
where it was like sometimes two and a
half X the voltage drop under a high
frame rate scenario was also
uncharacteristically high for this type
of card that's on the card side it's not
the power supply Ai and it's something
that is probably mostly unique to the
reference 700 xdx so board Partners can
fix this one between the coil line we
demonstrated the voltage regulation and
especially the aggressive V bios fan
ramp with improper hysteresis that
causes noisy fan Behavior we think you
should probably skip the reference model
and get a partner model instead so
that's not to say the GPU itself should
be skipped but there will be better
cards that should be at or just barely
above MSRP in theory we know that's
going to hurt some feelings because
people have a really strong attachment
to AMD reference cards for some reason
but that's just the truth of it so a
couple things here as we wrap up first
of all again we're obviously filming
this on the other side of the world it's
cool that we can do this we're back home
Patrick's been testing it and we've got
vitaliano team editing most of this
review remotely but I'm analyzing the
data from here and that means we're
doing our best with I mean still the
same amount of data we always have but
uh there are some some angles we want to
look at once I get back over to the us
so we can evaluate the card further so
we'll have some follow-ups there if you
feel like something's missing from this
review it's coming up soon it's just we
need to well I need to physically get
more hands on with the card once we're
back so just to get that out of the way
now with what we have here we think the
700x tx's value is better than the 4080
for non-ray traced gaming so like
rasterization it's pretty competitive
and a lot of the worst case scenarios
it's roughly equal you lose by maybe
single digit percentages so they're kind
of plus or minus eight percent between
the two cards depending what it is not
really that big of a difference but two
hundred dollars is a big difference and
even though the 700 XTX might not
commonly be available for MSRP neither
is the 4080. so they're kind of on equal
footing in that regard as well we think
that this is not a huge blowout victory
for AMD because so Ray tracing they're
still behind there and then there's
still just not anything in that
mid-range affordable where gpus should
probably cost for gaming category of the
market right now the 6900 XT for example
we just checked quickly they're still
out there for like 650 to 700 bucks it's
worth considering if you are cash
constrained to the point that an extra
200 300 is simply too much uh so the
3080 is also closer to 700 depending on
where you look these days and that's
still worth considering as well but
there's a clear lack of cards in the
affordable market and that's a problem
as for the 4090 it's still uncontested
at the high end so AMD doesn't have
anything to fight there and the one
advantage you always have when you are
the literal best as a video card is that
you're the literal best so the 4090 has
that angle to fight on where it doesn't
need to compete on price as much as
quality because well that's how it's
positioned but the 4080 is the one that
needs to it loses here and it does need
to fight a little harder Andy's done
well to push on video here uh next time
we'd really like it if AMD didn't talk
about 8K gaming because they have a lot
of actually meaningful advantages even
if only a price that they could be
marketing instead and those are much
stronger points than pretending that 8K
gaming is a thing anyone cares about
when the vast majority of the market
isn't even on 4K screens yet it didn't
perform that well either so other than
that the card looks pretty competitive
we think it's worth considering and
we'll be benchmarking it further once
we're back home but we have a 700 XT
review and an XTX teardown coming up
next so check back for those subscribe
for more as always you go to
store.camersexis.net or patreon.com
Gamers Nexus to help support us directly
because we're doing these reviews even
when we're traveling and when I have to
shout into a mattress to do a moldy
mattress that's leaning on the wall that
I probably shouldn't be breathing near I
have to shout into that to do the
voiceover so thanks for watching we'll
see you all next time